Richard with this Halloween is
unbelievable I mean you know I realized
Richard is a very rare adult he's an
adult but has a child's mentality like
just the other week Richard and his wife
went to Orlando to attend Halloween
horror night at Universal Studios and
this was the 22nd year in a row Richard
has attended this event yeah he's very
proud of that
yeah and Halloween Horror Nights on
takes place at night during the day
Richard kept himself in the Halloween
mood by reading the Halloween edition of
Woman's Day magazine by the hotel Pole
Wow and he wears headphones as he reads
the magazine so he can hear scary
Halloween sound of it right this one is
called cannibal eating person this is
what he's listening to by the pole you
went to haunted houses all night you
don't want to break from Halloween you
laid by the pool and read about
Halloween i immerse myself in the
Halloween universe here's another tape
this is Richard sitting by the pool this
is what he's listening to
[Music]
why is that why is that Halloween the
cuckoo clock well for me it reminds me
of the movie Evil Dead there's a scene
in Evil Dead where the clock goes crazy
did they have an Evil Dead haunted house
they have before in other years you know
what you know what this reminds me of
I think of like what much the noise and
Fred's head sound like and I think this
is it I do is it Fred no it's not okay
well the thing is I didn't only listen
to that stuff by the pool I listen to
these sound effects a week Labor Day
yeah well on the way to work and stuff
and it's funny and do you have a
calendar that likes to start listening
to Halloween sound effect I just know
around the end of August everywhere ela
start looking for you soon yeah but but
sometimes that like there will be a lady
screaming and my earphones and it's so
loud people will look at me like what
the hell are you listen this insane song
is called season of the witch jingle
from Halloween 3 oh that's one of my
favorite designs or a headphone and
you're sitting constantly
[Music]
it's almost time kids is ticking you
love that yeah I love it
it's from Halloween 3 which is maybe my
favorite movie such a [ __ ] weird guy
can you imagine Robin devoting this much
time to this the only reason he's not
living in a basement Howard is you I
know that's true thank you well even
worse was in a storage unit
this guy was living I would have killed
for a basement he was living in a
storage unit no bathroom nothing yeah
I'm a Halloweeny what kind of said no
you're more than no you're you're a guy
who goes to every weird thing and
anything you do normal you have to weird
it up yeah a lot of people like me well
there are a lot of people like you and
you know they're called seven-year olds
you know